[Music]
um
[Music]
is
yesterday the board of trustees voted
tenure for
professor church
and today he's following me around with
a stick
i explained to him he still can't hit me
with a stick
welcome to baccalaureate service
this is an old tradition
uh
from the beginning of the college and
any college
revived in recent years when we built
this chapel
we can fit now
and uh
i love this service
because it reminds us
the guide for all of our accomplishments
today we meet the argument
that our college or any such college
is unsuitable to teach the young in
public schools
there are two reasons why this is wrong
and silly
and one of them has to do with the
history of the country
and the other has to do with the nature
of learning
the public schools in our country are
founded in 1787 in one of our four
organic laws the northwest ordinance
it's the first time
a free government
ever grew without benefit of colonies
and there's only one policy issue apart
from setting up the government
described in that and it's in the
article three
and it says
religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind
schools and the means of education shall
ever be encouraged
this document was passed in the conf in
the
congress under the of confederation
in the same summer in the same city
that the constitution of the united
states was being written
there was much overlap
between the people who passed this act
and the people who wrote the
constitution
they did not apparently think it wrong
that
religion be in the public schools
you can find that in quotes from
most significant speeches and writings
and utterances of
george washington and thomas jefferson
all of them
the second reason is in the work we do
here
the work in which the seniors
are graduating from
but only to continue
in that work we find that there are
questions about how to live
we come here to address those questions
and the answers are always followed by
the question why
mr jordan peterson has asked me why four
times in a row this morning
and i was not surprised
i can't remember what i said to him but
i i did remember that i had some reasons
why is the question right
and each y
leads you up to some larger thing
something that resolves
the apparent problem
before you
and if you ask enough of them
you get up very high
you get up toward
perfection
you get up to the vicinity of god
thoughts go there
automatically they can't be helped
if it's true as it is true that the
the goods are arranged in a hierarchy
and it's obvious which ones are higher
than others
up to a certain point and then it's
one of my professors used to say
if you look at two mountains sticking up
into the clouds
it's hard to tell which ones are taller
which one is taller
but you can still tell them from a
molehill can you not
the implications of god and imperfection
are in all explorations of the good
and we do that here and that's why we
are so thrilled
is this the third time now i can't
remember
uh
that we get oh yeah the pandemic it
would have been the fourth time i think
we did it but
i might have gotten arrested
let us pray
for the future
of the senior class and every good thing
thank you
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
is
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
the scripture lesson is written in the
third chapter of saint paul's letter to
the philippians
beginning in the fourth verse
if anyone else thinks he may have
confidence in the flesh
i more so circumcised the eighth day of
the stock of israel
of the tribe of benjamin
a hebrew of the hebrews
concerning the law
a pharisee
concerning zeal persecuting the church
concerning the righteousness which is in
the law
blameless
but what things were to gain to me
these i have counted lost for christ
yet indeed i also count all things lost
for the excellence of the knowledge of
christ jesus my lord
for whom i have suffered the loss of all
things
and counted them as rubbish
that i may gain christ
and be found in him
not having my own righteousness which is
from the law
but that which is through faith in
christ
the righteousness which is from god by
faith that i may know him and the power
of his resurrection
and the fellowship of his sufferings
being conformed to his death
that by any means possible i may obtain
the resurrection from the dead
not that i have already attained or am
already perfected
but i press on
that i may lay hold of that which from
christ jesus has laid hold of me
brethren i do not count myself to have
apprehended it but one thing i do
forgetting those things which are behind
and reaching forward to those things
which are ahead
i press on toward the goal for the prize
of the upward call of god
in christ jesus
therefore let us as many as are mature
have this mind
and if in anything you think otherwise
god will reveal even this to you
nevertheless to the degree that we have
already attained
let us walk by the same rule
let us be of the same mind
here ends the lesson
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
glorious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yet indeed i also count all things loss
for the excellence of the knowledge of
christ jesus my lord
in the name of god the father god the
son and god the holy ghost
amen
psalm 84 which our choir so beautifully
sang just a few moments ago
is one of the great gems of the psalter
every bit has sonarists as psalm 23
and as penetrating as
psalm 51
and as visceral as psalm 139
this psalm psalm 84
ought also to grab our attention and
arrest our memories
as one of the purest expressions of
devotion in the entire psalter
traditionally ascribed by the old jewish
scribes
to the sons of korah
these were descendants within the line
of levites
who became doorkeepers and custodians of
the temple
over time they became custodians in
particular of the sacred music
in the temple
this context i think helps convey a bit
the psalms power
because while the sons of korah are
levites
they were not descendants of the line of
aaron
and so their clan of levites had no
stake in the priesthood
nor in the administration of the
sacrifices in the temple
their duties exclusively kept them in
the outer courts
forbidden by divine command
from even entering the building itself
all they could do was look from a
distance
and long
one may appreciate now why they express
a bit of jealousy even for birds who are
able to dwell
in the building itself
on these terms this psalm is an apt
expression of that angst that we all
feel when we've come to know our lord
and savior jesus as our savior
but we haven't yet come to see him face
to face as will be our inheritance in
the age to come
we have a noble charge
proximate indeed to the very throne of
grace we're commanded to approach it
with boldness
but the fullness of that divine embrace
yet lies in our future
and so like the sons of korah
true believers long
to be where god is
to know him even as we are fully known
by him
to behold him face to face
how lovely
are your dwellings o lord god of hosts
surely our knowledge of the excellent
bliss that awaits us is true and real
it is trustworthy we can bank on it
it is not merely an idle notion or a
pious imagining
we really have seen even if in a
fleeting glimpse
the glory that god that awaits god's
children
and we received a pledge of god's
earnest desire to bring us there by the
resurrection of his son our savior jesus
christ
and so
our souls have a desire and a longing to
enter
into the courts
of the lord
for we know that whoever dwells there
not merely as a passing visitor but as
one who shares in the very household of
god and calls him father
for these will always have their hearts
full of praise verse four
full of strength verse 5 full of safety
verse 12 and of blessing verses 4 5 and
13.
in such a place of bliss and of divine
beatitude even the place of the porter
at the door is better than any earthly
inheritance verses 10 and 11.
this psalm gives perfect expression to
our longing
for our heavenly home
now this future may seem a long way off
to all of you
here you are
on the cusp of life full of vitality
and accomplishment
confident with perhaps just a twinge of
uncertainty
but eager just the same to show this
world a thing or two am i right
graduating seniors is that your
disposition today
you are right
to feel this way you have indeed
accomplished a lot and today i salute
you and i honor you
in the midst of these moments of triumph
joy and accomplishment it can be good
for us to remember the heavenly
perspective
after all we meant to instill within you
these past four years a love
a desire to pursue the highest things
surely we have high hopes for how you
will now make a mark on this world for
the common good
how you will in your own ways make our
society just a little bit more humane
for life to flourish as god intends for
his creatures
and while that is so
you must remember today of all days
that the highest thing cannot be found
in the world below
as paul will say later
in this very chapter of his letter to
the philippians we have heard read this
morning
our true citizenship
is in heaven
and we eagerly await
catch that note of longing friends we
eagerly await
christ our savior from there
this is not our home
and this note of longing is every bit in
continuity with that of today's psalmist
paul would rather brazenly have you
consider the relative worth of earthly
accomplishment in today's reading from
philippians
grab your pew bibles page 818 if you
want to follow along in the texts
in the midst of a contest with would-be
apostles who are who are trying to win
the confidence of this congregation that
paul himself has founded in paul's
absence
in the midst of these would-be apostles
who like to to brandish their resumes
and their credentials
paul would
have some startling words to say
he admits at first his capacity for this
kind of game
verse 4 if anyone thinks he has
confidence in the flesh
i have more
so he says
the apostles resume is rather impressive
he is an israelite by birth circumcised
on the eighth day and
indeed he can trace his lineage all the
way back to one of the twelve sons of
that great ancient patriarch jacob
he is a hebrew of hebrews he says which
is actually a semitic linguistic
construction that is superlative in
english he is the most hebrew of all
listen to his words
concerning the law
a pharisee a member of that most
scrupulous follower of the law
concerning zeal persecuting the church
so zealous is he for the traditions of
his fathers
concerning the righteousness which is
found in the law
blameless
by any earthly standard paul's resume is
impressive
educated by the best gamaliel he tells
us in his letter to the galatians
ambitious beyond his peers he also tells
us in that place a demonstrated track
record of zeal
pure blooded singularly minded all out
to be the best man of god he could truly
be
truly a religious marine if ever there
was one
semper fi huh where are commissioned
officers today
paul can certainly play the game of
resumes
but what
does he think of these things now
having now encountered the resurrected
christ
on the road to damascus
he tells us in verse
7. but what things were gained to me
these i have counted a loss
for the sake of christ
in other words whatever boosts his
confidence on earthly terms is is
actually a detriment in approaching
jesus as lord
why
again he tells us
because in comparison to him
all else
pales
and remember these words were written by
a man who when he first saw christ
was blinded by the encounter
besides his blinding radiance these are
nothing but faintly burning candles not
even distinguishable
in front of it
i count all things lost for the
excellence of knowing christ jesus
my lord
did you catch that friends
these monuments of earthly glory these
these resumes in which we might boast
aren't even being held up to christ
himself
but merely to the knowledge
of him
to know him to relate to him to take
hold of him
this on the human side
turns all earthly glory
to dust
it is rubbish as paul says which is a
word in greek of harsh even vulgar
connotations earthly glories are in
other words filthy street garbage refuse
sewage
however much luster they may have from a
merely natural perspective deserve the
vulgarity that paul offers to them here
when they are compared to christ's
heavenly glory
paul would rather give it all up
if he could only be found in christ's
paul would rather have the righteousness
which comes from god than whatever can
be had in mere religious observance paul
would rather suffer with jesus knowing
that such conforms him more closely to
our lord paul would rather walk the way
of the cross if it means eternal life in
the age of the world to come
so precious indeed is his vision of the
exalted christ
is your vision of the exalted christ so
precious to you today
so much does he long to behold the fair
beauty of the lord and to dwell in his
courts forever do your hearts long today
all else for the apostle is filthy rags
and so he strains forward the image here
is of a of a runner at the end of a race
reaching forward that he might cross the
line before the other runners
forgetting the vanities of the world
which lies behind with all its pomp and
prestige
and lurching forward with all of his
might for the prize that awaits him in
heaven nothing less in fact than the
embrace of christ himself
well done thou good and faithful servant
enter into the joy of your master
i must be careful here
paul of course is not above using the
stuff of his earthly resume to advance
his mission
indeed he often uses these things to
powerful effects
his knowledge of the hebrew scriptures
for example no doubt acquired during his
time as a pharisee is a powerful tool in
his tool belt to proclaim the exalted
christs
his colorful rhetorical skills no doubt
acquired during his years as a zealous
jewish student are the basis of his
equally colorful and sublime letters
which we read today
his zeal once expressed in persecuting
the church is hardly spent by his
conversion to christ now it is merely
redirected toward the advance of
christ's kingdom
paul does not let me be clear utterly
reject his resume as completely
inconsequential
he does however
caution us against putting any of our
security in it
for paul
these things only have a purpose now in
so much as they can be leveraged to the
all so that he can moral all the more
eagerly press on toward christ
in christ alone
does paul find his hope
his worth
his security
his purpose
his mission
and there can be no question about the
immense earthly impact of paul's
heavenward push
as we hear gentiles in far flung
hillsdale michigan now two thousand
years hence from the time of the apostle
are still reading his words
more importantly we are still worshiping
his god
let me turn this wisdom of the apostle
now back to you
you have been been given these past four
years an incredible education
you have been personally invested in by
professors
mentors and friends
you have honed your skills and clarified
your own vocations
and now what remains is the simple
question here on the cusp of your
commencement
so now what
i urge you today my friends to aim
higher
aim higher than career aim higher than
accomplishment aim higher than prestige
and power aim higher
aim
for jesus christ
consider him above all earthly treasures
consider him the only true satisfaction
of your soul
push with all your might that you might
hear those same words that of the
apostle no doubt heard many years ago
enter into the joy of your master
ponder in your hearts the excellence
of the knowledge of
set your mind on his inestimable
benefits
he offers us pardon
he offers us healing
he offers us true belonging he offers us
embrace
he bestows upon us his resurrection
power to conquer sin and the devil
he shares with us his eternal wisdom
that we might know and discern rightly
he extends to us his heavenly riches
that we might taste and see of the
divine glory and know that it is good he
commissions us as his very own soldiers
and ambassadors to extend the reach of
his heavenly kingdom here and now he
invites us into his own good work from
the beginning of the world
to make a world that reflects the glory
of god
consider the dignity he bestows upon us
consider the depths of his teaching
consider the lavishness of his
generosity freely giving us divine
adoption calling us his friends sharing
with us his counsels comforting us in
our perplexities atoning for our shame
granting us hope for the resurrection of
the dead
and what does he ask of us in exchange
for all of these riches friends
he asks you only
for your trust
all these heavenly riches
can be yours quite apart from any resume
you might offer to him
simply by faith
that's why paul considers in fact his
resume a loss
you cannot offer anything for what jesus
is expressly intending to give you for
free
he will not allow his generosity to be
obscured
take it by faith
take him
by
faith go into the world and live
with humble faithfulness
serve bless honor the dignity of our of
all by all means my friends try and make
a difference
but in all these things aim higher aim
for the highest thing
aim to know jesus christ as your lord
aim to take hold of him aim to secure
his embrace aim with confidence that you
can because he himself has given you all
the means to do though and assurance
that he means for you to do it by his
blood shed for you
and by his life raised for your
justification
he has given you victory in his own
human flesh
he has given you already his very self
aim for him and you will never know real
loss
for he alone lives and reigns with the
father and the holy spirit one god in
glory
everlasting
amen
the lord be with you
let us pray
if you have a kneeler in front of you
you're invited to nail
lord have mercy upon us
lord have mercy upon us
our father who art in heaven hallowed be
thy name
thy kingdom come
thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses as we forgive
those who trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
deliver us from evil for thine is the
kingdom and the power and the glory
forever and ever amen
in the name of the father and the son
and the holy spirit amen
as we gather here in your name father to
celebrate our commencement we give
thanks for all of the blessings you
bestowed upon us in our time at
hillsdale
thank you for giving us families who
supported us in our journey and who are
there for us to help nurture our
pursuits
without our families and the gift of
life none of this would be possible
today
maybe go forth and form families of our
own and build a civilization of love and
truth thank you for your providence in
placing us in this institution that is a
light and a troubled world and may we
spread this light by living out the
mission of the college wherever we go
when you bless hillsdale college keep it
true to its form and continue your
wondrous work in all who come here
thank you for our professors who have
supported us every day to help cultivate
our mind and soul
none of us would be who we are without
the help of these beautiful minds
keep our professors grounded in you
focused on high ends and help them to
form virtuous souls
finally we give thanks for the
friendships we have formed here which is
perhaps the greatest gift you have given
us
you brought us together so that we may
love one another heart to heart soul to
soul so let me encounter a glimpse of
your profound love for us
let us never lose the friends we have
made and may we take this gift of
friendship to multiply your goodness
with all we encounter as we enter the
world
thank you for your works of conversion
and performing us into better human
beings you've inspired repentance you've
taught us how to pray to worship and
you've illuminated our minds to your
truth
you've increased our faith our hope and
our love and maybe continue to strive
towards holiness every day
we love you lord and we thank you
may we never forget our heavenly end and
may we glorify you in all that we do
give us the grace to love and honor you
as we ought and bring us into your
eternal rest we pray this together as a
class and as a family in the name of the
father and the son and of the holy
spirit amen
jesus as we come together to bless your
name we are in awe of all you have done
in the past four years
and even as we reflect on your goodness
and faithfulness we know that this is
just the beginning
your nature that we experienced here at
hillsdale is only a glimpse of the
future glory to come
we thank you jesus that revelation
promises that your testimony is the
spirit of prophecy so who you have been
is who you are and who you will be
as we go out into the world and begin a
new chapter of life we believe that you
will be the same faithful god that
carried us through our highest highs and
lowest lows during our time at hillsdale
you have been faithful you are faithful
and you will continue to be faithful
and we believe that we will see your
goodness in the land of the living as
you send us out in your name
we exalt you jesus we re-enthrone you on
our hearts
as you have been faithful to us these
past four years we ask that you would
teach us to be faithful to you for the
rest of our lives
you have been the true prize this entire
time at college and you will continue to
be our prize as we enter into this next
chapter
we recommit ourselves to you jesus
lord we ask for your blessings as we are
sent forth
would you guide and direct our steps and
would you be the voice behind us that
says this is the way walk in it wherever
we turn
we ask that you bring us closer to your
heart in this next season and all the
seasons to come
would we each carry your presence with
us wherever we go
and be your witnesses of the truth to
the ends of the earth
may you the god of peace sanctify us
completely and may our entire spirits
souls and bodies be kept blameless at
the coming of our lord jesus christ
you who call us are faithful and you
will do it
so we as your body and your bride say
yes and amen
maranatha come lord jesus
let it be done unto us according to your
perfect will
we honor you lord and we love you
all is for your glory
we pray these things in the name of the
father the son and the holy spirit amen
almighty god
who has guided and provided for these
young men and women to this day in their
lives
we thank you for all the ways in which
you have brought them up and your faith
and fear these past four years
we thank you for wise teachers
faithful mentors and good friends
we praise you for lessons learned in
hardships and in triumphs we bless you
for treasured memories and for the hope
of the next season to come
we acknowledge you as the good shepherd
who leads us beside still waters
to green pastures
we ask you now to bless them as they go
forth from this season of their life to
the next
guide them on their journey
strengthen them in their work
comfort them in their perplexities
and above all establish them in the
knowledge and love of you and of the
gospel of your son
remind them always that they are ever
walking in your sight
and that you work for the good in all
things for those
you have called according to your will
may you be their anchor in their stay in
the coming days weeks and years ahead
may they never go a day without an
assurance of your love
the prompting of your spirit
and the power of your risen son in their
lives
and may they at the last
find their rest and their peace in you
alone
all this we ask through their lord and
ours your son jesus christ
who with you and the holy spirit lives
and reigns one god
now and forever
amen
let us bless the lord
thanks be to god the grace of our lord
jesus christ the love of god and the
fellowship of the holy spirit be with us
all evermore
amen
please stand for the final hymn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you